juan quiere saber si una máquina
automática en un restaurante llena las
bebidas con la cantidad correcta toma
una muestra con 20 bebidas para probar
su hipótesis nula que es la media real
de la población es decir la cantidad de
refresco que tienen las bebidas y que es
igual a 530 mililitros contra la
alternativa la cual dice que la media de
la población no es igual a 530
mililitros donde muy es la media de la
cantidad llenada las bebidas en la
muestra tienen una cantidad media de
llenado de 528 mililitros con una
desviación estándar de 4 mililitros
estos resultados dieron un estadístico
de prueba dt igual a menos 2.200 36 y un
valor aproximado de 0 puntos 0 38 supón
que se cumplen las condiciones de
inferencia cuál es la conclusión
apropiada para un nivel de significancia
alfa igual a 0.05 aquí nos dan varias
opciones y como siempre los invito a que
pausa en el vídeo y traten de resolver
el problema por su cuenta resolvamos
esto juntos tratemos de comprender lo
que está pasando aquí tenemos una
población de bebidas y no sé
a la media verdadera de la población la
hipótesis nula dice que la media
verdadera de la población es igual a 530
mililitros y la hipótesis alternativa
dice que la media verdadera no es igual
a 530 mililitros para probar la
hipótesis nula tomamos una muestra de la
población de tamaño n igual a 20 de esa
muestra calculamos la media muestral y
la desviación estándar muestral que son
estos datos indicados aquí ahora con
esta información incluyendo el tamaño de
la muestra podemos calcular el
estadístico t ya que tenemos el
estadístico t podemos calcular el valor
p el valor p se refiere a cuál es la
probabilidad de obtener un resultado que
tenga al menos este extremo si suponemos
que la hipótesis nula es verdadera si el
valor p es menor que el nivel de
significancia entonces decimos que es
una probabilidad muy baja por lo que
rechazamos la hipótesis nula y
sospechamos la validez de la alternativa
aquí la clave es comparar el valor p con
el nivel de significancia el valor p es
cero puntos 0 38 y es menor que el nivel
de significancia de 0.05 debido a esto
vamos a rechazar
la hipótesis nula lo que nos hace
sospechar la validez de la hipótesis
alternativa que dice que la media
verdadera no es igual a 530 mililitros
veamos las opciones que nos dan la
opción a dice rechaza la hipótesis nula
hay evidencia de que la cantidad media
de llenado es diferente de 530
mililitros esta opción luce bien pues
sugiere que la hipótesis alternativa
puede ser válida veamos las otras
opciones para asegurarnos de que no son
correctas la opción b dice rechaza la
hipótesis nula no hay suficiente
evidencia para concluir que la cantidad
media de llenado es diferente de 530
mililitros no esto no es correcto la
opción se dice no rechaza la hipótesis
nula ya vimos que esto no es correcto
porque el valor p es menor que el nivel
de significancia así que la tachamos la
opción de tampoco rechaza la hipótesis
nula por lo que no es correcta también
la tachamos hasta aquí terminamos y nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo